Oh, [music]
[music]
[singing]
from distant lands, from [music]
valleyies white,
we rise with hearts both firm [music]
and try.
Arriving where the garden bloom,
[music and singing] a blessed ground, a
sacred room, we gather not for name or
fame, but for the Quran, the sun [music]
has flame.
In an age veil thick with doubt, truth
is blurred, addition shout. [music] The
prophet's path is pushed aside, the sal
no more our guide. Though here we stand
with soul [music] sincere [singing]
seeking light to make it clear.
Though [music] the road is steep and
long
we stand unshakeen
firm and strong [music]
beneath the banner of the companions
bride
who [music] walked with him who saw the
light.
They knew his words. The verse is
[music] true.
Their path alone
safely through.
[music]
Follow them salvation
door. [music]
Without them
darkness floods the shore.
Oh. [music]
Oh, [music]
>> here we bind our hearts as one, [music]
>> choosing the path of the chosen one.
>> With Quran and Sun, side by side,
[music]
we march as one. No need to hide through
knowledge built through deeds made pure
through da firm. We [music] shall
endure.
To you alone, oh Lord, most high, our
souls. Submit [music] our hopes light.
Shower us with guiding light. Keep our
steps upon what's [music] right.
Though the road is steep [music] and
long,
we stand unshaken,
firm, and [music] strong.
beneath the banner of the companions
[music]
bride
who walked with him who saw the light.
They [music and singing] knew his words.
The verse is true.
Their path alone [music]
safely through.
Follow [music] them salvation
door.
[music] Without them, darkness floods
once [music] more.
[music]